[Musique]
bonsoir
j'imagine que ce que nous sommes tous
très contents d'être là vous êtes là
pour passer un bon moment
apprendre des choses partager des
émotions bref vivre un instant de
bonheur simple
il ya quelques années j'ai découvert sur
internet une vidéo de nick bougies tic
un conférencier australien né sans bras
et sans jambes
dans cette vidéo on le voit pêcher à la
ligne sauter d'un plongeoir glisser le
long d'un toboggan aquatique et tout ça
avec une intense joie de vivre qui
illustre vraiment son amour de la vie de
mon côté d'une manière nettement moins
spectaculaire mais activité mais
attitude témoigne de ma joie de vivre et
ce soir je vais vous donner trois clés
pour aimer la vie votre vie même lorsque
surviennent les bouleversements les
épreuves les traumatismes
le 6 novembre 2003 en allant à l'école
maternelle où j'enseignais au tout petit
j'ai eu un accident de moto qui m'a
rendu paraplégique
j'ai passé dix jours à l'hôpital
dix jours super c'est parce qu'il était
dans la perfusion mais j'ai eu des rêves
pleins de couleurs de lumières et de
joie
à un point tel que j'ai écrit un poème
malgré la perte de liquide
céphalo-rachidien qui faisaient que mon
écriture était toute tremblotante
d'ailleurs je ne pouvais ni lire ni
regarder la télévision
avant mon accident j'étais judoka
ceinture noire 3e dan
septième au championnat de france
universitaire du temps où j'avais des
cheveux
dès les premiers jours de
l'hospitalisation
je me suis dit avant tu étais fort
physiquement tu étais mal dans ta tête
et bien maintenant tu seras fort dans sa
tête
même si tu as la colonne vertébrale sera
cassée et j'ai écrit ce poème que j'ai
intitulé l'homme arbre à caen événement
heureux il n'espérait rien sur la glace
du temps il file est immobile il
regardait le monde avec la liberté d'un
chien tandis qu'au fond de lui
le lou a phone se voulait volubile
mourir semblait lui être son devoir
s'ouvrir fut l'âme de son espoir alors
severance forte et et feuillus
harmonieusement se déployèrent au dessus
d'eux lors d'un tapis de tournesol gorgé
des flamboyantes et amicale lumière
racines flamboyante de son envol et j'ai
signé gg 1 g minuscule suivent et des
suivis d'un g majuscule parce que
j'étais intimement persuadé que grâce à
cet accident
jallet grandir bien sûr tout le monde ne
réagit pas comme ça chacun son histoire
mais moi j'avais la pêche parce que
j'étais vivant et une pêche vraiment
communicative dorénavant tous que
j'allais vivre
c'était du rab
j'aurais pu nourrir ce 6 novembre 2003
maintenant qu'ils allaient me goinfrer
de vie grâce à la paraplégie
j'ai vécu et je vis toujours des moments
qui sortent de l'ordinaire par exemple
des conférences de l'onu à new york ou
encore et des stages de danse à san
francisco un festival de cannes un ted x
j'ai toujours été actif d'ailleurs
lorsque j'étais encore fonctionnaires
pour l'éducation nationale souvent on me
demandait mais comment tu fais pour
faire tout ça et je répondais c'est
grâce aux femmes
et oui toutes celles à qui j'ai déclaré
de la flamme ont dit non et donc il faut
bien que je m'occupe et oui tout n'est
pas toujours rose
la vie n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille mais plutôt une chaîne de
montagnes avec des sommets plus ou moins
majestueux et dévalé plus ou moins
encaissé
comme beaucoup de personnes valides ou
porteuses de handicap
j'ai souffert de la solitude j'ai aussi
été mariée en sept ans de vie commune
nous sommes disputé que deux fois
j'étais à l'aise dans mon ménage je ne
posait aucune question sur l'avenir de
notre couple la seule frustration venait
de mon désir de paternité
en effet pour mon épouse c'était un
deuxième mariage elle avait déjà deux
filles sa deuxième fille ayant des 17
ans lorsque nous sommes rencontré la
femme ne voulait pas se remettre dans
les couches ce que je comprenais notre
deuxième altercation est survenue
lorsque je lui ai fait part de mon envie
d'acheter ma 25e moto elle s'est mise en
colère et elle m'a dit comme si elle
avait un pressentiment
gérard si un jour tu es en fauteuil
roulant moi je ne te pousserait pas j'ai
quand même acheté ma mille suzuki gsx r
six mois plus tard j'ai eu l'accident 80
après elle a demandé le divorce
je pense que sa décision a été actée
parce que psychologue du centre de
rééducation lui a dit madame votre mari
avait des comportements à risque c'est
pas parce que maintenant et d'un
fauteuil roulant qu'il n'en aura plus
cette demande de divorce m'a surpris
mais ne m'a pas détruit par ce que j'ai
vu en elle l'opportunité de devenir un
jour papa de même quelques années plus
tard en me rendant en trike c'est une
moto à trois roues
un premier rendez vous galant j'étais
tout guilleret la tête dans les étoiles
quand soudain derrière moi retentit un
coup de klaxon surpris je me suis
rabattu un peu trop brutalement sur la
droite
et comme je ne maîtrisais pas tous les
abdos j'ai été éjecté du véhicule
allongé de tout le monde sur le bitume
j'ai appelé la dame de dépenser elle est
arrivée sur les lieux de l'accident
quelques instants après les pompiers est
allé récupérer mes affaires dans le
coffre du trike les a amenés à
l'ambulance et m'a dit au revoir en fin
de compte c'était un adieu
je n'ai plus jamais vu ni même entendu
pendant deux jours j'ai été dévasté
la tête pleine de pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi ça m'arrive à moi là
je voulais même pas vite pourquoi enfin
premier rendez-vous après des années de
solitude
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi troisième
jour j'ai trouvé une réponse
ma réponse j'ai fait un parallèle osé
entre mes questionnements et ceux des
personnes qui étaient rentrés dans un
magasin pour faire leurs courses et qui
en était ressorti sans leurs jambes à
cause d'un attentat et comme je venais
de faire un stage d'écriture théâtrale
je me suis dit qu'avec ce ressenti et
toutes ces questions j'allais pouvoir
écrire une pièce de théâtre qui pourrait
faire du bien aux gens à partir de là
tout allait bien j'avais donné un sens
positif à ce qui m'était arrivé donner
du sens c'est ça le truc
la paraplégie à donner du sens à ma vie
maintenant à mes yeux j'ai une mission
participer à la modification du regard
porté sur le handicap
c'est comme ça que je suis devenu
comédien et conférencier et que je me
retrouve devant vous ce soir
maintenant il est temps que nous donner
trois clés première clé accepter le plus
rapidement possible ce qui est
irréversible ça sert à rien de se
rajouter un ulcère à l'estomac deuxième
clé faire le bilan de ce que vous avez
pas de ce que vous avez perdu car c'est
avec ce que vous avez que vous allez
pouvoir rebondir et troisième clé
chaussez vos lunettes d'opportunités
fait des liens fait des ponts avec des
choses qui sont tout à fait improbable
soyez curieux et inventif osé voire
l'opportunité dans les bouleversements
dans les épreuves dans les traumatismes
dans les crises et vous aimerez la vie
votre vie est maintenant pour finir sur
un bourg un beau sourire
voici les références de la vidéo de nick
boulistique know i'm no l'ex no worries
merci
[Musique]